millionen von menschen hat das
apollo-programm diesen großen traum
erfüllt und das obwohl es so schien als
hätten die usa den wettlauf um die
vorherrschaft im all schon lange
verloren
ihr habt euch dieses wirklich sehr sehr
spannende thema bei was apple gewünscht
danke dafür bekommt jetzt die vier
wichtigsten facts zum apollo programm
wie genau lief die krasse aufholjagd im
weltall ab hat die apollo-mission
überhaupt stattgefunden und welche
tragödien mussten auf dem langen weg zum
erfolg verkraftet werden also herzlich
willkommen bei pixum science fiction 61
eroberung des weltraums ein spannender
wettlauf mit aufholjagd kein weltraum
projekt wird der menschheit mehr
eindruck hinterlassen
us präsident john f kennedy hatte beim
entwurf des apollo-programms eine große
vision dabei wurde der weltraum in
mehreren etappen erobert und den ersten
teil hatten die usa jedenfalls gegen die
sowjetunion verloren und zwar zum
zweiten mal sputnik der erste satellit
war 1957 von den russen gestartet worden
und der sowjetunion gelang es auch den
ersten menschen ins all zu schicken
1961 war das der kosmonaut juri gagarin
also sah es lange so aus als seien die
amerikaner bis aufs letzte abgehängt der
weltraum war zu dieser zeit tatsächlich
der schauplatz an dem das ultimative
kräftemessen der beiden großmächte
ausgetragen wurde
die großen fragen wer schafft es als
erster nach oben während als erstes
seine flagge in den mondboden in seiner
rede vor dem amerikanischen kongress im
mai 1961 kam noch einmal der letzte am
sport vom amerikanischen präsidenten
himself zitat unsere nation sollte sich
verpflichtet fühlen vor dieser dekade
einen mann zum mond zu bringen und
sicher wieder zurück auf die erde den
amerikanern setzte er damit seine große
vision ins ohr
die landung der menschen auf dem mond
und damit war das apollo-programm
geboren zwei perfekt größte trägerrakete
weltweit deutsche luftwaffe war
beteiligt vor allem die entwicklung
einer leistungsstarken trägerrakete
stand im fokus der amerikanischen pläne
unter steuerte auch die deutsche
luftwaffe ihr wissen hinzu
die herausforderungen die trägerrakete
musste der erdanziehung entkommen und
ein bemanntes raumschiff in den weltraum
befördern das endergebnis die saturn 5
die mit ihrer höhe von 110 metern noch
immer zu den größten raketen der welt
gehört gerade habe ich sehr als bausatz
von lego gebaut das ist schon ziemlich
fasziniert ihre leistung ist tatsächlich
phänomenal ihr startgewicht lag bei
2.880 tonnen
das dreistufige trägersystem hatte eine
schubkraft von haltet euch fest 160
millionen ps und die saturn 5 erreicht
eine spitzengeschwindigkeit von 39.000
kilometern pro stunde und so dauert es
nur 60 stunden bis die trägerrakete die
astronauten zum mond gebracht hatte
das absolut paradoxe der großteil des
gewichtes war dazu da das große gewicht
der rakete nach oben zu befördern
fast ein fliehendes ziel aber am ende
schaffte es die rakete raumschiff und
mondlandefähre zum mond zu bringen
ein bruchteil des gewichtes an sich
bestand das apollo raumschiff aus drei
komponenten im kommando module waren die
instrumente angesiedelt um es zu steuern
hier lebten die astronauten auch sie
aßen und schliefen beispielsweise hier
das haupttriebwerke und die elektrischen
systeme sowie die kommunikationszentrale
befanden sich im service modul in der
mond lande einheit hatten zwei
astronauten platz
damit konnte man auf der mondoberfläche
landen und auch wieder zum kommando
modul zurückkehren dritter effekt nur 17
der geplanten 20 missionen fanden statt
der start des apollo programms war im
jahr 1967 mit apollo 1 insgesamt zwölf
probe für gewann geplant bis der erste
astronaut tatsächlich auf dem mond
landen sollte und der anfang vom ganzen
wurde tatsächlich zur tragödie
drei astronauten sollten einen monat vor
dem ersten flug der apollo-11-mission
die raumkapsel testen doch die
ingenieure hatten eine technische
schwachstelle übersehen
einige werfen der nasa sogar vor im
rennen um die erste mondlandung
nachlässig geworden zu sein es gab ein
feuer im cockpit die
sauerstoffversorgung der raumanzüge fiel
aus die drei männer verbrannten mit der
apollo 8 gelang dann später die erste
bemannte mond umrunden und apollo 11
beinhaltete dann endlich die erste
mondlandung doch anfang der 70er jahre
drehte sich die
stimmung der amerikaner hinsichtlich des
apollo-programms aber bis dahin hatte
die nasa auch schon sechs erfolgreiche
mondlandung hinter sich und so wurde das
budget der weltraumbehörde gestrichen
und nur 17 der geplanten 20
apollo-missionen konnten stattfinden
das alles verstand kosten von mehr als
20 milliarden dollar wirtschaftlich
gesehen gibt es noch heutzutage
diskussionen darüber ob das wirklich
notwendig war an dem ganzen
apollo-programm waren zudem eine halbe
million menschen beteiligt vier perfekt
die apollo-mission fanden statt immer
wieder wurden die apollo-missionen von
laien in frage gestellt allerdings
verfügten sie nicht über das fachwissen
und die optischen und physikalischen
kenntnisse die nötig sind um die video
und fotoaufnahmen vom mond zu beurteilen
warum sind keine sterne auf den fotos zu
sehen warum wird die amerikanische
flagge im wind wieso sind manchmal
dieselben hintergründe zu sehen alles
gar nicht mal so komplizierte
sachverhalte die aber ohne sachkenntnis
nur schwer verständlich sind wer sich
jedoch ein wenig darin vertieft wird
alles ziemlich schnell verstehen und
umgekehrt konnte noch niemand nachweisen
dass wo und wie die mondlandung hätte
inszeniert werden können mit dem
damaligen filmischen möglichkeiten wäre
das nämlich schlichtweg unmöglich
gewesen selbst kinofilme waren in dieser
perfektion nicht möglich und eine so
umfassende dokumentation mit foto film
und video hätte wahrscheinlich noch mehr
gekostet als eine echte mondlandung wenn
ihr kein video verpassen wollt auch
extra videos und livestreams nicht dann
werdet mitglied hier auf dem kanal
einfach hier unten wunder draufklicken
wir kriegen dann auch noch ein paar
privilegien dazu und unterstützt uns
wird einen kleinen betrag einfach eben
auf mitglied werden klicken direkt unter
dem video ein riesen dank an all
diejenigen die schon dabei sind das
macht uns etwas unabhängiger von den
schwankenden werbeeinnahmen hier auf
youtube wenn er immer informiert werden
wollt überall aktuellen videos und nicht
über die etwas unzuverlässiger box das
kennt das schon
whatsapp einfach draufklicken kostet nix
und ihr kriegt jeden tag eine meldung
wenn das video online geht und zwar
sogar etwas früher als hier auf youtube
und am besten auch meine schwester cara
klicks um social media abonnieren dafür
klicken und nicht die glocke vergessen
und hier geht es war damit dafür auch
darauf klickt menschen sollen auf dem
mond siedeln bis dann bleib dran